[موسيقى]
مرحبا في نهايه الموسم الدرامي الرمضاني
اعتاد المشاهدين ان يقدموا قوائم حسد
مختلفه عن ابرز الاخطاء الدراميه طوال
الشعر اعمال رميقه تكون نجحت الجماهيريه
لكنها مليئه بالاخطاء الدراميه مسلسل ازاي
يعني بتمثل من فتره من زمان وتلاقي كاوتشه
اديداس في المدرسه
شويه احنا مش هنقول اكتر في الاول وفي
الاخر تمثيل
فاكيد اكيد ما فيش حاجه ما فيهاش اخطاء
اكيد في حاجات ورده اخطاء يعني هو في خطا
كده في سرك بس عدى شويه يعني ما حدش يركز
فيه خلينا نحكي الاخطاء مش كاخطاء تمثيليه
لكن انا لمستها واعتبرتها خطا اللي هي
المشاهد الفاضح في بعض المسلسلات
واعتبرتها هاي خطا ما كان لازم تكون
موجوده في هذا الشهر الفضيل ولا بالايام
الثاني طبعا
خطا انه في مسلسل
العمده انه دارك طلعوا له ابنه انه احنا
ما شوقونا نعرف وين ابنه فدايركت انه طلع
ابنه يعني ناخذ نلتمس لمعذر انه ممكن يعني
يحراج او انه ما انتبهوا او انه يعني بس
فيه كانت اخطاء وواضحه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات